oh my god here we go
a performance so good it had Carrie Ann
Inaba falling out of her chair we have
that effect on our fans yeah they
weren't kidding after Kate Flannery and
her pro partner Pasha performed a Mary
Poppins seemed jazz on Monday night's
episode of Dancing with the Stars Carrie
Ann Inaba fell out of her seat at the
judges panel and onto the floor
it wasn't my fault Carrie Ann Inaba
falling out of her chair first time in
Dancing with the Stars history she's
fallen before but she did get up she's
fallen before listen anything can happen
on this show I mean my biggest fear is
tripping and falling on my dress so it's
like it's live TV it's what we love
right
[Applause]
you guys ran over to help her up of
course of course I mean I didn't
understand what happened everything
happens so fast I think somebody said
cockroach was all like a spider or
something like that and I think she
reacted and she put back whatever it was
you know it's like goes in slow motion
when you see you want to help you like
she's down state dancer down but you
know what she picked herself up she
dusted herself off and she started all
over again so here we go cheers were
going to be trouble of course
cariann being the pro that she is was
able to laugh it off both on the show
and later on social media she shared
this screenshot of the mishap on
Instagram writing um so that happened I
don't think anyone saw it so let's just
keep it between you and me
[Music]